welcome back to dc thursdays i'm
pete soderling i am your sherpa through
the data ecosystem
we talk to leaders of open source
projects we talk to
data co-founders of companies and
generally give you the information
you need to know about the emerging tech
data space
so i wanted to thank all of our
listeners and audience who have been so
faithfully attending these programs over
the last
six plus months we've built up quite a
following and
um you guys are generating a lot of buzz
in the community
for us we're glad that you've been
enjoying the guests and
we want to continue to to bring the show
faithfully to you so thanks for all your
support
and as you know we have a special format
around here
where you get to ask questions in real
time
uh in the chat in on youtube so
we're excited to make this these amazing
guests available to you and
um please take advantage of feeling free
to jump in the chat at
any point in time you might have a
question for our guest so today i'm
i'm super excited to invite patrick
thompson
who's the co-founder and ceo of
iteratively
i'm patrick welcome and thanks for
joining us today
thanks for having me yeah glad to have
you as the sherpa along this journey
well i do my best and it's super
rewarding to be able to talk to so many
smart folks in the data ecosystem
and and now you're here so um with your
yellow background so we get to
have a fun have a fun shot today so
um just to get started so people have
some context as to
where you come from i know that you sort
of ended up at atlassian
immediately before iteratively and i'm
sure there's lots of interesting
lessons learned there but but talk to us
about the
earliest stages of your career um how
did you get involved
in data yeah no uh yeah good question
for me my background's primarily in
business academically
uh i have a business degree but actually
originally started as a cs in
information systems
in academia and then ended up switching
out to business and getting my master's
in business but my first job was
actually more doing conversion rate
optimization
so using tools like site catalyst and
testing target and really trying to
improve
e-commerce performance that was my kind
of first
step into using data to actually help
drive growth for businesses
and that got me into design and how do
you know how do
customers and users think and what is
the psychology behind
uh those steps that they take within
their
their their journey and that really kind
of ended up giving me uh
the first step into design which i then
transitioned over into more of a product
design rule and then ended up moving to
the bay
working at a variety of different
startups there but really kind of
always taking my business background
and trying to understand what success
looks like and what the outcome for the
business and the customer looks like
and applying that to the work that i do
and eventually i ended up meeting my
co-founder
now andre at his company simplicity and
we worked together for about three years
uh primarily in the the sink insurer
space and then i ended up joining the
last scene because
i was really passionate about solving
problems for software teams
and joined the growth team there where
again it was very
design led it's the best way to describe
it and then uh
yeah it inevitably ended up leaving to
go work on
you know a second act together with
andre with iteratively
fascinating so there's a business
background
there's a design background there's even
some interest in cs from from back in
the day
it's fascinating how you put all those
all those things together
yeah master of none that's just jack of
all trades
and and now you get to add startup
founder and ceo to your list
you must be you must be afraid of
nothing oh yeah no it's
definitely a culmination of all the
fears come together as a founder but
this is definitely the the most exciting
stuff i've had in my journey so far
well i'm sure that this this journey of
working your way through product design
and
really embracing the way users see
and benefit and interact with products
um
it's it seems obvious in in the way that
it sort of led you
to start iteratively um but what was the
core
insight um i typically find that
founders have some key insight regarding
why they start their company um what
what was the key insight and and when
did you see
when did you receive that that led to
you starting iteratively
yeah uh so to be to be completely frank
andre actually knew we wanted to
solve problems for startup teams but we
didn't know what problem we wanted to
solve we knew
uh you know we were basically just
dropping
the you know planning on building the
airplane on the way down and jumping off
the cliff so we left
i left the last in the beginning of 2019
and we spent about six months doing
customer research
primarily talking to data analysts
growth marketers
uh data scientists engineers just trying
to see what pain points that they had in
their day-to-day
that's kind of when we ended up hearing
repeatedly issues that customers were
having with the data that they're
capturing
how that on how they were using that
data internally and so that's really
what led us to the insight was primarily
just
customer development and just listening
to the pain points that folks had
and inevitably after about six months we
did a bunch of research ended up
uncovering this particular insight that
we had and decided to build a company
around it
and so how did atlassian at the time for
example
capture data around products a good
question so we actually the the exact
problem that we ended up pairing from a
bunch of different companies we had
atlassian and
while i was on the grow team we built a
bunch of an internal tooling to actually
help solve this we built our
experimentation platform we built our
own audience management platform we
built
our own event collection platform and
these were all things that
inevitably we hadn't stitched together
and the biggest pain point that we kept
on seeing time and time again even at a
last scene was just not
trusting the data that we're capturing
quite often it was messy
inconsistent and unreliable and so i was
really surprised
i thought this was just an lasting
problem i was really surprised when we
went out and talked to a bunch of other
companies and they were having
similar pain points and having to build
similar tooling outside as well because
there was no real good solution for them
to use to solve this
at a lasting we ended up building kind
of a black list you can think of it as a
registry
that would effectively operate as a data
dictionary and would validate all the
data flowing into the data pipeline
uh you know put bad data into
a dead letter queue and then validate
the data and let it pass through to the
data warehouse
or into third-party tools like amplitude
that was something that we spent you
know
i think even today there's a team
working on maintaining that
infrastructure internally
um and yes our goal at iteratively is to
avoid folks having to build their own
solutions or to build a better solution
than any team could do
and manage internally so they don't have
to you know they can go work on more
higher value ads
for for their business and you must have
spoken to
um many other customers or potential
customers
during those days i'm sure some of which
were
maybe represented by the larger tech
companies of atlassian size who were
likely i assume solving this problem on
their own internally
yeah we did i mean at this point we've
been over 450 interviews uh across the
board
uh many many organizations we saw
obviously
there's the there's the atlassians the
airbnbs the ubers
the hubspots the circle ci's the air
taskers who had all built internal
tooling the cloudflares of the world the
cameras of the world
they all had built internal tooling
nothing in the market was really meeting
their needs
they were potentially migrating from
third-party solutions to
first-party solutions when they're
building their own data platforms as
well
and uh yeah we took a lot of inspiration
from the tooling that we saw them
building internally and decided to kind
of
productize something that was uh
effectively
you know similar to what they had done
but just in a slightly different way
focusing on collaboration across data
consumers inside the organization
and then focusing on building out a
best-in-class developer experience for
instrumentation as well got it
um well let's let's jump into um a
little bit about
iteratively um talk to us
um as concretely as you can about what
the product does
and um why it's a massive need you
mentioned that
you discovered that data quality was an
issue at atlassian in terms of the event
data and the product data that you were
capturing
um you know talk to us about sort of the
the guiding principles behind italy
iteratively and how it solves these
problems
yeah happy too and i think it's probably
worth jumping into kind of some of the
pain points that we see
companies struggle with when it comes to
their customer telemetry their click
stream the behavioral analytics data
that they're capturing
and how they're using this data as a
business obviously it's very easy
to think of this data the data use cases
here for
bi and reporting and understanding the
performance of your products
what are the key success metrics that
you have there's other use cases
around marketing automation or using
this data to trigger
campaigns and onboarding experiences
and or even in product messaging as
another example
there's a bunch of companies using this
data for personalization or retargeting
so there's a variety of different
stakeholders and consumers of this data
within an organization
but inevitably what we kept on seeing
time and time again is you have data
consumers on one side of the table and
data producers on the other
and that the best thing that most
organizations had to really
try to corral this mess was a
spreadsheet or a confluence page or some
sort of wiki
that they're using to define their
analytics with iteratively we wanted to
kind of build a best-in-class
collaboration platform where people can
go and define all their events
all the data that they want to capture
all the properties of these events
a really easy to use application that
kind of applies a lot of the same
principles that we get
from software engineering around
versioning and
peer review and apply that to
schema so effectively you can think of
it early as really twofold one's a
schema registry where you define your
analytics
and the second thing is a developer
toolkit that developers use that
really takes that schema and generates
type safe sdks that improves the overall
quality of the data that you're
capturing
integrates it into your existing test
suite whether or not you have
integration tests with cypress or
selenium or just
and then also integrates with ci cd to
effectively break the build if analytics
break up stream
we want to be as proactive when it comes
to solving
these issues not reactive solving them
downstream
once you've already released new
software
got it and so how is your schema
registry
um how does that compare with this sort
of
data dictionary that you described from
the atlassian days are have there been
meaningful advancements in that
particular piece of the stack or
is that um like talk to us a little bit
more deeply about how that works
yeah the last one was pretty simple it
was just uh it was a web application
that we wrote that allowed somebody to
go and define an event and a set of
properties or json payload for those for
that event
and then would validate it against that
the iteratively registry takes a lot of
the same principles but
uh a much easier ui to use for
for non-technical folks like product
managers and analysts who are the ones
who are typically maintaining the schema
internally
and we've also built in a lot of
integrations with downstream tools
or even upstream tools as well
specifically around like being able to
notify teams when things are changing be
able to have approval process and kind
of
better tackles or rules and permissions
across the organization
so quite often in the bigger
organizations that we work with box as
an example
they want to be able to review any of
the changes that are being made to that
schema
and any of the new instrumentation
that's being defined so that
as an example you're not capturing pi
information and sending that to
downstream third-party s solution
so we built a really good review process
around the entire
process of defining your analytics and
getting that actually instrumented by
developers so we have a lot of the
similar concepts like branching
and pull requests built into iteratively
as well
so what's an example of um bad data
in a system like how does bad data in a
sense um
bad customer data bad product analytics
data
um how does how does this show up
downstream what are some
concrete examples of that the the three
easiest examples that we see
all the time is one like you have your
ios teams and internet called users
signed in and your android teams and an
event called user logged in
and downstream those are representatives
to particular events but if you're a
product manager an analyst you have to
go then create a join
a munch the data to actually get to a
particular business metric that you're
trying to answer around
how many logins that we have for the
business and this happens time and time
again
and so iteratively we solved that
problem by creating a single place where
you go and define that event you
associate it across those two different
teams and each of the teams get an sdk
that matches
exactly what you need as a data consumer
the other thing that we see quite often
is developers
and setting a string instead of a number
or float instead of an int
not really thinking through a lot of
what property is actually sending or not
giving you the right properties
that you need downstream in order to
particularly meet the use case that
you're using that data for
um and the other thing that is pretty
common as well is
generally analytics is untested and a
bit of an afterthought for most
organizations which means that it breaks
pretty frequently
so you might have a developer go in
refactor some code
inevitably they drop an event or they
change a property
and no one understands until it's too
late you've already shipped that change
to production
uh your dashboards break your machine
learning models break
your marketing automation breaks and
then inevitably you either have to try
to get a hot fix out the door or you
have to wait to your next release cycle
to fix it and that happens pretty
frequently with folks
and there's just no real good way for
them to detect these issues
uh other than building out their own
anomaly detection systems or
hoping that somebody inevitably just
looks at a report
and detects it that makes sense
and so then who are the main users
of the iteratively product how do you
define your ideal customer profile
and sort of what different touch points
and groups around the business
typically integrate with it yeah we
primarily work with sas b2c
and e-commerce companies today uh the
folks that we typically work with
in and who bring us into these
organizations are the data team so it is
the head of data head of bi the head of
analytics
who inevitably have teams who are
consumers of this data typically data
scientists or data analysts who
are pretty much hamstrung by the quality
of the data that they're capturing and
they have no real good framework
to bring your product manager on board
to bring your engineers on board to
kind of corral this mess so those are
typically the folks that we work with
very much analytics is a team sport we
want the product managers to be involved
we want the engineers to be involved we
want the data analyst to be involved
to think really about what success looks
like for their business and then to be
able to represent that
into kind of a lower level schema that
gets defined in the events that get
defined inside of your
your inside of it really
so then do you effectively operate as a
sort of a data
router in the middle of these um all of
this event tracking or
like where do you sit architecturally in
the value chain yeah so we're as far
left as you can get so you can think of
iteratively as kind of a governance tool
workflow tool on top of your analytics
schema and it will generate the sdks
that sit inside of your source code so
we
integrate into all of your different
platforms including ios android your
backend
your front end wherever you're emitting
events from and
we sit there and we'll actually send the
data directly to any of the destinations
you want to send that data to
including tools like amplitude or
mixpanel or segment or
snowplow analytics wherever you want to
route that data will actually federate
that data directly from the client
once it's actually validated and passed
uh past validation
uh and then initially if you have your
own data pipeline you have something
like kinesis or kafka set up with a
particular endpoint
you can actually wrap your own
third-party api
or your own third-party analytics client
and send data to your own custom data
platform as well
so you start at the collectors you you
are the javascript bugs that
that are instrumented in web pages
that's that send this uniform data
um and those bugs are sending uniform
data because they're generated by
sort of the the core um iteratively
schema registry slash brain that um is
being used by the customer to define the
core metrics in the first stage that's
correct yeah we have a cli that
developers use to auto-generate those
sdks and those sdks include
exactly 141 what was defined in the spec
inside of the registry
got it so there's no transformations
required it's not like you're
taking data from other people's sdks or
trackers you sort of
assume that it's your tracker that's
been that's been instrumented
um in in the in the end application
correct
that is correct got it um and how did
you think about the
the tracking component of this because
there's obviously a bunch of companies
that
that do similar things i think you chose
to
open source your trackers is that right
um so you you must feel like i mean
talk to me about that that notion and
sort of strategically how you got to the
point where
you decided to open source those bits of
your of your platform
yeah i mean we've been very thoughtful
about what with the open source and what
kind of
remains closer at least for the time
being with it early i think one of the
things that we think about from an open
source perspective is how do we build
enough value from an open source
perspective where you can still maintain
value even if you decide to migrate off
of iteratively
uh but today when it comes to the sdks
like this is code that you're shipping
as part of your production software
so we want to make sure that there's no
issues long term if you decide that you
want to migrate off of iteratively or if
this wasn't a good fit
we'd be sad to see you go but we want to
make sure that you don't have any
obligation
to rip out our source code so everything
that ships in your client is yours to
keep it's very much open source
code there's no dependency upon our
platform
that's neat that's awesome um well let's
let's dig into some more of the
downstream features
i mean i think i i have a better
understanding now of what you mean by
by tracking plan you talk about tracking
plan and some of your collateral
and essentially that's that's the
interaction of the customer
with the schema registry to define what
they want tracked
perhaps what they don't want tracked and
then
you also mentioned that there's some
collaboration and
branching features is that surrounding
the tracking plan or talk to me about
how you've overlaid some of these these
typical traditional software engineering
notions um into this concept of
of customer data tracking yeah no a
great question and when we think about
tracking plan tracking plan is kind of
the
industry terms canonical example of what
the data dictionary looks like
and for iteratively you can think of
iteratively as just a contract between
all the different folks within your
organization
so if you have a product manager an
analyst a data scientists data consumers
of these events
it allows you to effectively create a
contract between those consumers and the
engineers who are actually responsible
for emitting that data to
whatever data pipeline or tool that
you're sending that data to
and one of the things that we saw that
was pretty apparent early on
is the fact that we wanted to apply a
lot of the best
you know best practice engineering
example is around versioning and
collaboration to
schema similar to what is done to code
so iteratively is a effectively a
version controlled schema registry in
the sense that
every event is version so if you were to
change a particular
event at a property as an example we
would increment or auto increment based
off scheme over
we took a lot of inspiration from all
the fine work that the folks have done
at snowplow analytics
to make sure that you know effectively
you can think of your schema as code and
be able to evolve it over time as your
needs of the business change
uh vice versa we want to make it really
easy for you to understand backwards
compatibility or incompatibility changes
on schema so
you know if you effectively have a
required property that required property
has to be required for the life of the
event
what is the impact downstream on your
data warehouse if
you were to evolve that schema if you
were to add additional properties or try
to change the property types of that
like this is all a lot of complexity
where folks generally don't understand
the downstream impacts of changes that
they make upstream when it comes to
tracking
that we're trying to at least surface to
folks as they go about
changing the schema at the same time
that you
can version the schema or
move at a different spot in time to a
different schema
i assume the tracking values the
the data itself um can be referenced
against that
older schema if you wanted to so so
you're not you're essentially not losing
any data through that process
is that the way it works correct yeah
you're not you're not losing any data
the other thing is
all versions of the schema are always
queryable so you we have a browseful api
where you can use to query
all the schemas you know request a
particular version of this game or
request all schemas or request all
versions of a particular
event as well and the nice thing about
that is we do have customers who
actually use those schemas to do the
the data validation as part of their
pipeline as well so
effectively makes it really easy if you
decide to change things to validate it's
a new schema or validate your old events
against an old schema if you have a
particular old version of an ios client
or an android client out there in the
wild still
uh effectively making it you know at
least effectively making the data that
you end up that ends up into your data
lake or data warehouse
high quality great um so what are some
other
features of iteratively that we should
know about
yeah uh good question i mean right now
we're primarily focusing on improving
collaboration
and improving quality of the data that
you're capturing one of the things that
we're actually really seeing next month
which we're pretty excited about
is the ability to give you some
inferences on making sure that the
schema is actually validating
so today we don't process any of your
data so really been a
really helpful thing for us but actually
being able to know
as part of usdfc like hey what how many
events aren't passing schema validation
what new events are we seeing that may
not be using the strongly typed sdks as
an example
or very much feature requests that we're
getting from our customers
so we're launching a feature next month
which will
allow folks to get a better sense of the
quality of the data that they're
actually capturing and routing to
their third-party analytics providers
and this and this is implemented by
discovering some data that's not
explicitly being captured
is that right correct so this is this is
implemented by
us being able to process the metadata
around your analytics events
previously that might not necessarily be
defined with the
iteratively analytics sdk
got it really interesting um
so we talked about commenting and
branching
um we talked about the developer
experience about the schema registry
are there security concerns with the way
data flows through
iteratively and and other customer data
platforms
um how do you how do you think about
security and user privacy and all those
things because obviously
data governance and privacy is a always
a hot button issue
um especially as more customer data um
starts to be captured by by systems
100 i mean it's the first question that
comes up typically when we work with
larger enterprise organizations as well
i mean the next thing today is that
everything integratively is configurable
and by default we don't process any of
your customer data so you don't have to
worry about
us being a data sub processor in the
context of gdpr
we work with many many customers who are
in europe and the nice thing about the
way that we've designed the system and
architected it from the ground up is
that
we don't have to worry about that in the
sense the only data that we see is your
employee information related to
the users and roles within our platform
and then the metadata around the schema
which has been super helpful um
effectively one of the things that
customers actually look
for it really four as a solution is ways
to actually enforce better rules and
governance
on what analytics they actually do
capture about their customers
so one of our key value props is around
actually enabling kind of creating that
data map for organizations on combining
what data that they're capturing why is
this data being captured how's this data
being used downstream
and effectively giving them guide rails
on being able to approve
or reject any changes to the tracking
pawn
that data consumers might be making
yeah i can see that as being a core
benefit of the centralized schema
registry is that
it allows for an easier audit and sort
of
understanding across business functions
of what data is actually being captured
because if it's not in the schema
registry
um it shouldn't it shouldn't be captured
at least at least not by iteratively
there yeah there's a huge problem and
like this is one of the biggest pain
points that we heard when we're doing
customer discovery is like
i have this data flowing into my data
warehouse i have no idea where it's
coming from
and then obviously event lineage comes
up quite often
and it's a really hot topic within this
space but like for us like we're in
source code so we know exactly where
each event is being emitted from
to the line number in source code uh and
then like where that data is being sent
so like there's a huge advantage for us
in that particular
realm and then being able to tie into
like tools like tvt downstream
for documentation and something that
we're very excited by
so that you know you as a data consumer
i know exactly from
how that what report you're generating
all the way to where it's being admitted
so if there is a problem you can
actually go easily debug it
um and understand kind of the impact
that that problem has on your business
got it so we have our first question
from wyatt thanks wyatt for the question
uh so far
you mentioned monitoring internally
generated events ingested by an
analytics team
are there use cases where a data service
provider could publish this
to another company consuming the data
we've had we've had a few requests for a
capability like this
from a few of our customers who do
publish like kind of
events that their customers use
we haven't done anything particularly to
enable that there is one feature that we
have which is around public
documentation so
the schema that you store inside of is
always exportable but we also generate
public docs here
and it is obviously queryable and you
can send a link to anybody around the
documentation for your
events that you you have we obviously
see a lot of folks
wanting to create an event dictionary
that they share with their customers
and then kind of be able to productize
or export
like you know different uh reports using
look or other types of tools for
external reporting so we do see this as
something that we might be able to help
facilitate but we haven't done anything
particularly
useful here other than being able to
generate external documentation
and where does iteratively store the
data because presumably that data could
be
grabbed by the customer and sort of
piped out to other places or shared with
other
other partners manually if they if they
preferred is that right
yeah i mean all the schemas are
exportable so we don't actually store
any customer data in the sense of like
your end users data but we do store the
schema and that schema is always
exportable so you can export that as
json schema you can send that anywhere
else
and we always generate always up-to-date
documentation so similar to swagger if
you've ever used swagger for api docs
we have a link that you can send anybody
related to
what's the current state of tracking for
your business
got it cool so
um in terms of sort of taking a step
back and and thinking about
the broader market um the the the
customer data platform
world is um full of
um competitors and
people throwing elbows and different
products and tools
how do you see yourself as sort of
fitting in that world
more broadly how do you position
iteratively either to be
collaborative or competitive with other
solutions yeah there's there's a lot of
pointy elbows but like generally we're
very complementary to many of the tools
that exist out there today including the
amplitudes the mix panels the
the segments the writer stacks of the
world so like we're not we're not trying
to
uh we know exactly kind of where we add
value which is specifically around kind
of governance of analytics
um for us like our number one goal is to
improve the quality of the data that
you're capturing
so that you can trust it downstream and
you know there aren't that many
other options that teams have today
beyond a spreadsheet or building an
internal solution
so that's kind of where our motives our
mo
at least today is when we think about
ways that we can help in the future it
really comes down to
improving the overall collaboration uh
being able to provide you some level of
monitoring and visibility into the
health of your analytics
and then yeah partnering with really
good partners who
care about this as equally as much as we
do and we are doing
a lot of partnerships today to actually
kind of help facilitate
uh better communication and
data capture for tools like amplitude
and mixpanel as an example
got it um i guess what you know my my
notion of
of the industry and sort of the way it's
emerging has been
you know you have the the two-ton
elephant
in the room which is kind of segment and
um
sometimes they get to be expensive for
particular use cases um
they're quite expansive in their product
features um they're a hosted platform
and so
you know they they can charge what they
want to some extent
it seems like there's a whole new breed
of tools that are popping up that are
kind of
picking away at certain portions of what
segment does
and allowing a savvy team to essentially
sort of um create a bespoke
tracking customer data infrastructure
internally and you've mentioned snowplow
you've mentioned tools like dbt which
are more general but are still i think
used in some of these workflows
it seems like you sort of fit a
particular piece
of this this bespoke stack where
a customer can sort of recreate their
own segment
um with either open source or closed
source tools but other services that are
really best to breed at doing
one specific thing in this whole value
chain is that
is that a fair way to sort of see the
industry and the way it's
emerging right now definitely fair and
like one of the people i really like is
ben thompson he always talks about
bundling around
laying in software and like you could
effectively think of
a lot of these bespoke tools that are
merging is doing one thing very very
well that segment has done in the past
obviously segment has changed their
pricing and we work really well with
segments today and we have quite a few
segment customers
um but we do see other companies who
decide like hey this isn't necessarily
the right thing for us given the cost or
given our growth or
we us at least wanting to own our own
data so we do see
teams who are using iteratively as kind
of a a way to kind of govern those
analytics that they might have been able
to do in other tools
in the past and that has been very very
helpful for us at least early on
for our growth and then yeah partnering
with either companies like snowplow for
the
datawarehouse integration or be able to
federate the data to third-party sas
tools which we do natively today
is there a typical customer deployment
of iteratively
do you see the same two or three tools
you know on the right-hand side of your
integrations like
consistently like how how what what's
most popular in terms of a
typical customer implementation yeah i
mean i think like in broad strokes i
think the
the two types of destinations that folks
try to build out into their dataset is
obviously integration with the data
warehouse
whether or not that's using something
like snowplow or custom data pipeline
or using something like amplitude data
pipelines as an example and then putting
the data into amplitude and then using
vivetran or something else to move that
data to their data warehouse
we do see folks wanting their event
streaming data in the feather data
warehouse and then into
third-party sas tools like amplitude to
enable sort of self-service analytics
for other consumers within their
organization that's pretty
typical of what we see other things that
come up pretty often are things like
iterable or braze
or apps flyer or more of these marketing
type growth platforms for for messaging
and attribution
uh so those come up quite often when you
think about kind of a broader
growth stack that teams are trying to
build at least when it comes to their
event streaming data
um see that's that's pretty clear
obviously i'm a huge fan of gbt uh i
love what the
what love what they're doing so we see
that as kind of
probably one of the fastest growing
tools at least of the customer
conversations that we're having
and uh yeah that definitely does a
really good job when you think about
kind of being able to build audiences
or on top of your data warehouse um that
does that definitely does come up as
well
yeah got it um i wonder if you have
thoughts on
um sort of the next generation of
of tooling as well because i it seems
like i've been having this chat with
founders and
we've spent the last five plus years
really
working to the left of the data
warehouse and there's tools like
iteratively and snowplow and others that
are
dbt that are sort of getting the clean
data finally
into the data warehouse so that can be
used
um i wonder if we're we're sort of
getting ready for the next
iteration of that evolution where
the tools to the right of the data
warehouse or built on top of the data
warehouse sometimes is the paradigm
used will start to be quite interesting
um
because you know getting the data into
the clean data into the
the data warehouse even though it's been
all consuming for us for the last you
know
five plus years now that we're starting
to have
systems that that are getting us there
now some of the questions starts to
shift to
oh my god now what can i do with this
data i can pipe it to my
sales marketing apps um and there's
tools like hi-touch and census that are
popping up
to do that do you have any view of sort
of that side of the
of the space um are there are there more
things that people can do
with data um that gets through
iteratively ends up in the warehouse
that they haven't even thought of yet
yeah no good that's a good question and
i think operationalizing the data
warehouse as a source of truth is like a
huge advantage that companies
have uh that hasn't really been
i think powerful enough at least in the
past with the existing tools and the
existing vendors on the market
i think the source of truth inevitably
will end up becoming the data warehouse
i think
being able to have kind of reverse etl
solutions makes a lot of sense
i think the question obviously comes
like are they only reverse ctl solutions
are the
you know elt and you know
like and the reverse side like all built
into one tool is obviously
kind of an ongoing conversation that the
market has um
i'm actually really interested in kind
of the data cataloging space as well
like you have like data hub and a bunch
of other types of tools that are
emerging
which obvi obviously when data warehouse
becomes a source of truth and you have
uh an explosion of data consumers who
are using that as a source of truth like
how do you manage that and how do you
govern that as well
so i'm very excited about what they're
doing um
and then yeah i've chatted with the the
census and high touch team and yeah i
think that they're on the right path
uh there's a bunch of other tools that
are emerging there now as well it's
definitely an explosion within that
space
yeah it'll be fascinating to see how the
next five years
plays out and um what we can do with all
this clean data
um thanks to companies like italy
um you know now that we have clean data
in the data warehouse yeah
so um as you know we're very much a
community oriented
organization i started data council
as a meetup in 2013 and became a
conference in 2015
we've been working with the data
community for a long time
i'm just curious as to sort of what your
vision and values are
for iteratively as a community
you know as a company participating in
the data community
you know sometimes it's it's easier
perhaps for a straight up
full-blown open source company to like
do that community thing because that's
kind of their lifeblood and they kind of
have to um but i
i know that you have thoughts on um the
way that
iteratively um can be a good actor in
the overall ecosystem and i'm curious to
hear like how you've
um how you're shaping the culture of the
company and some examples of ways that
that you're doing that yeah no and i
think this is probably
one of my favorite questions so far so i
mean for us like we want to be super
authentic
with who we operate with how we operate
as a company
and we've been and we spent six months
doing customer discovery so we got to
know this community before we ever had a
product before we wrote a single line of
code
and found the value and the willingness
to help that a lot of people extended us
as we were
newcomers into this community and so
definitely want to have the same
mentality
of paying it forward and providing
immensely more value than what we're
taking away
and that's kind of been how we've been
operating from the get-go and uh there
are plenty of people that are probably
going to listen to this who i cannot
tell you how thankful i am for your
support um and
you know generally like i think the
things that i like the best about the
data community is how helpful people are
it's been interesting transitioning from
building tools for software teams
primarily engineers and product managers
to building tools for
for data analysts um and data scientists
and hesadata
uh yeah it's just been a very humbling
experience to
have folks be very open with providing
feedback and support
um and i think when we think about the
company that we want to build you know
it's definitely
one where culture is super important for
us um
we were very determined before we even
made our first hire to
define and codify what our culture with
the culture that andre and i wanted to
build
for the company that really came down to
things like being super transparent not
just
internally with our employees but with
our customers and the overall community
uh being impactful like we wanted to
obviously
we left really nice jobs to go be
impactful make a difference in this
world and
we found a problem that we're really
excited to solve for a community that
we're really excited to be part of
and the last was to be inclusive and
make sure that we're
allowing other voices to be heard and
allowing folks to feel like they can
bring their
whole selves to work um and that was one
of the things that we were very
motivated to do and that comes into
these values are everything from how we
make decisions as a business to who we
decide to hire and how we decide to
engage with the community
we're very authentic in that and we hope
that comes across with the folks who are
listening to this and the folks who've
engaged with us
in the past and other communities as
well uh yeah that's that's kind of how
we operate as a business and i'd say
like one of the things that i'm very
thankful for is to have folks who've
joined us
on the on this journey who care about
these values as much as we do as
founders
yeah that's great well you have a lot of
good company in data space
in terms of um you know people who
appreciate
um what you're doing and what and the
value that you're able to bring and
as as we said before there's an
explosion of tools and all
um you know sort of um spot tools and
different natures of the space and so
i think being a good actor and um not
just from a company value standpoint but
um it sort of filters down into you know
practical things like integrations and
how you integrate with other
other people and i think that that's
definitely a way to
to do good and to and to um and to win
you know in this ecosystem because it
requires a very much of a collaborative
collaboration effort 100 um on the
company building side
like what what are the biggest lessons
you've learned
starting a company because obviously
there's lots of folks
um in our community who are thinking
about leaving their
cushy tech job maybe and um venturing
out and
and starting something in the data world
and we like to support them and
give them advice where we can so now
it's your turn to give them advice
um like what what what have you learned
um what were the gotchas
um what are some nuggets of wisdom that
you can pass on to the community
yeah i think uh for me it's it's
probably the most valuable experience
i've had
so far to be honest so i'm i'm very
thankful to have this opportunity
and the privilege to be able to go to
start if not everybody can do that
very fortunately from that perspective
i'd also say like you're not always
going to
get it right and like be okay making bad
decisions and being frog and having to
learn from those mistakes
so there's definitely many mistakes that
i've made over the last two years and
and lessons i've had to take away from
that so but understand that like that's
part of the
experience as well like you'll grow from
that i'd say the other thing that was
super important for us is we spent a lot
of time doing customer development
i i wouldn't trade that for anything in
the world like that was
how we got our first customers that's
how we realized that we were
building a problem or we found a problem
we're solving and building a product
that people would actually want to use
and so that whole experience was
immensely helpful for making sure we
weren't wasting
the years that we had on this planet to
just build a product and hope people
came
and we hoped that we were building the
right thing um
we're very customer-centric with what we
do uh and then
lastly again like your early customers
define you so like making sure that
you're partnering with people who
share your vision who are going to be
very good thought partners so we had the
opportunity to work with
you know teams great teams like dribble
and beekeeper and artifact uprising
and they were very very instrumental in
in getting us to where we are today
and so uh yeah i'd say like you are
defined by the people that you work with
and the customers that you have
defined by the customers you keep yeah
it's true
not all customers are good customers so
that's also another election
versus the company you keep yeah um well
this has been a great a great chat
patrick um i'm curious
just before we let you go um is there
something that's been particularly
surprising
for you about your work in the data
ecosystem so far
yeah it's uh i mean for me it's it's
interesting
we're very methodical about kind of how
we approach design
and product in the sense of like we're
solving different challenges for a
different community than we were
building you know tools for software
teams coming from from the last name
but there's a lot of similarities when
it comes to obviously tooling is only
one aspect of the problems
like tooling doesn't solve
organizational issues and there's a lot
of obviously organizational issues that
we can
that's a whole nother whole another
podcast that we need to get into
another webinar the organizational
issues when it comes to
software very similar to when it comes
to data and we have a bunch of things
like tdd
and cd and extreme programming that have
kind of emerged out of the
agile space over the last 10 years
as a outcome of
outcome of similar problems that i
observe in the data space
i'm very confident that in that regard
we'll see
similar changes in the way that teams
operate specifically within the data
community over the next
few years you know i already see some of
those changes happening today
uh and dbt is a great example of a tool
who's helping facilitate a lot of those
kind of
organizational change or best practices
that come from a software engineering
background
there are other tools that are emerging
there as well but i think yeah the
space is still very much in kind of its
infancy and there's going to be a lot of
progress made step change differences
made over the next few years so
yeah very excited to see what that looks
like and hopefully help be able
to provide some help there ourselves
yeah for sure there's lots of lessons
that we've learned as an industry
um when you think about it the the
software development field
is not you know it's only a few decades
old and so in the same way that software
development
process has evolved and changed over
time
and now we're starting to apply overlap
of some of those
those those insights to the world of
data in
mlaps and data quality and pipelines and
transformations and other things
i think it's we're in a really golden
era of data tooling
and so um it's great to see um more
thoughtful people like yourself
you know applying um lessons learned in
in previous careers for previous
generations of their career and then
sort of bringing those best practices
and that mentality to the data
engineering the data science the
analytics world i think it's
it's definitely required and really
salute you for your clear thinking and
that
uh in that way thanks yeah it was great
to have you patrick um
thanks for for being with us and for
sharing your wisdom with our community
it's great being here
so just a couple announcements um before
we wrap
up i want to let people know that a data
council has been running our 2021
open source data tools survey it's
caught
on like wildfire in the community um
we've had
hundreds and hundreds of responses
thousands of tools
referenced in the survey there's one
more day to complete the survey
before friday tomorrow we'll put a link
to it in the chat window and so we'd
love it if
everyone listening would fill in your
favorite open source data tool share it
with your friends it's basically a one
survey question
we made it as dead simple and as
as quick to take as possible so you can
literally do it in 20 seconds so please
do that and sound off on your favorite
open source tools
in the community also just a reminder to
folks who are listening
i'm a four-time startup founder myself i
love to help engineers and other people
in our community figure out
how to get their companies off the
ground i have a few office hour slots
that i make available for the community
every month
i'd welcome you to um click through if
you want to talk to me for a half an
hour
share with your share with me your idea
get feedback
i love to have office hours with the
community and so um just wanted to put
the call out for folks there that might
want to take advantage of that
um finally next week we'll have matt
rocklin from
coiled the doubt the company behind desk
we're really excited about that